Landing a high-profile movie role doesn't
always guarantee you'll actually be featured
in the picture. Just ask these actors, who
were famously—or some might say infamously—fired
from their roles mere weeks, or even sometimes
days, after cameras started rolling. How could
that possibly happen? Well, prepare to see
some of your favorite movie characters in
a whole new light.
Eric Stoltz
From the get-go, the team behind Back to the
Future wanted Michael J. Fox as Marty McFly.
Only they couldn't have him, because he was
tied up shooting his hit show, Family Ties.
So, they went with another actor: Eric Stoltz.
According to Indiewire, director Robert Zemeckis
and producer Steven Spielberg realized weeks
into production that Stoltz wasn't getting
many laughs in rough cuts of the film. Plus,
he reportedly went full "method actor" on-set,
demanding that everyone refer to him as "Marty."
"Marty!"
"Marty, I'm sorry."
Co-star Tom Wilson stated that he got a particularly
aggravated experience during a fight scene
between Marty and his character, Biff Tannen.
Eventually, they fired Stoltz and brought
in their original choice. Re-casting Stoltz
ultimately proved to be a wise business decision.
Back to the Future was a smash hit, and went
on to become a beloved classic. For his part,
Stoltz told Moviehole in 2007 that getting
fired was a "freeing" experience in retrospect.
Still, the situation sounds pretty heavy...
"There's that word again, heavy!"
Samantha Morton
In the Oscar-winning movie Her, the computer
operating system that Joaquin Phoenix's character
falls in love with was initially voiced by
actress Samantha Morton. All went smoothly—until
the film's team got to the editing room.
Director Spike Jonze explained what happened
at the 2013 AFI Fest:
"Samantha was really involved in giving Joaquin
[Phoenix] a lot…to work from. And then when
we got into editing, we realized that what
Samantha and I had done together wasn't working
for what the character needed. So, we ended
up having to recast at that point in time."
Morton's eventual replacement: Scarlett Johansson,
who filmed her dialogue around her Captain
America: The Winter Soldier schedule.
Harvey Keitel
Apocalypse Now was plagued by production headaches.
"The horror..."
Among the worst: when director Francis Ford
Coppola had to fire his leading man, Harvey
Keitel, shortly after the film started shooting.
Reports claim the two disagreed with the portrayal
of Keitel's character, Captain Benjamin Willard.
Keitel was replaced by Martin Sheen—who
suffered a heart attack during the infamously
difficult production—and Apocalypse Now
went on to massive commercial success and
nearly universal critical acclaim.
Lori Petty
Just two days into filming Demolition Man,
producer Joel Silver fired actress Lori Petty,
reportedly over "creative differences." Her
replacement: a young star named Sandra Bullock.
Petty later spoke about her firing in a 2014
interview with The Daily Beast:
"It was the most uncool day in Hollywood for
me. I just treat people the way I want to
be treated, so I’d rather not gossip about
his unkindness."
Sean Young
Dick Tracy from 1990 originally had actress
Sean Young in the part of love interest, Tess
Trueheart, but she was replaced soon into
production. Why? A profile of Young by Entertainment
Weekly said she was fired "for not seeming
maternal enough."
However, Young claimed the firing was a blessing,
telling the LA Times: "I don't think I could
have survived working with Warren Beatty."
She later alleged in an interview with Movieline
she was fired for refusing Beatty's sexual
advances. For his part, Beatty has denied
the accusations.
What, she didn't like the jacket?
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which fired performers should've made
the list...